dass seine aussage solche kreise ziehen
würde hatte jens spahn wohl nicht
erwartet der cdu-politiker äußerte sich
vor mehreren wochen über das
arbeitslosengeld 2 im volksmund hartz 4
hartz4 bedeutet nicht armut sondern ist
die antwort unserer solidargemeinschaft
auf armut so sparen im märz das wollte
sandra schlensog so nicht stehen lassen
die alleinerziehende gelernte
bürokauffrau bezieht mit unterbrechungen
seit fünf jahren die sogenannte
grundsicherung
sie startete eine petition sparen soll
seiner aussage korrigieren und einen
monat von hartz 4 leben anlässlich der
übergabe der petition trafen sich am
samstag unterzeichner um noch einmal
ihrem unmut luft zu machen mit dabei
natürlich die initiatorin
mich hat er gar nicht so getroffen weil
ich eine relativ starke person bin aber
mich hat für so viele menschen getroffen
die hartz4 anhängig sind es sind ja auch
aufstocker arme rentner darunter kranke
ab das ist ja eine 1 millionen von
menschen sind betroffen
und wie gesagt dass er das dann einfach
leugnet das ist das was mich verletzt
und was mich echt sauer macht sandra
schlensog hat es offenbar geschafft
menschen in verschiedenen
lebenssituationen für das thema hartz 4
zu interessieren
das hier ist eine ähnliche katastrophe
es ist unmöglich und es ist ungerecht
und das war's die fahrer schlenzer oder
gemacht hat ist eigentlich ein super
exemplarischen sprechen will
wie jemand politisch wird mit kuchen im
gepäck traf sich der heutige
gesundheitsminister anschließend mit
schlägen sorgt in ihrer wohnung in
karlsruhe
medienvertreter sollten nicht dabei sein
eine gemeinsame schriftliche
presseerklärung werde es geben
so hatten ist die organisatoren der
petition angekündigt ein gutes gespräch
miteinander alles mutter nach rund 90
minuten stieg sparen wieder ins auto
ohne kuchen tüte aber dafür mit den
eindrücken einer begegnung mit sandra
schlensog